Kita fikir komputer quantum akan membolehkan kita menyelesaikan sesetengah masalah lebih pantas daripada yang kita boleh dengan komputer klasikal sahaja. Tapi
memahami caranya adalah halus. Hari ini dalam Qiskit di bilik darjah kita akan cuba mendedahkan sumber kekuatan
pengiraan quantum dengan melihat salah satu yang paling awal
algoritma. Selamat datang ke Qiskit di bilik darjah. Dalam siri ini kita akan guna Qiskit untuk meneroka beberapa konsep asas
yang biasa diliputi dalam kursus berkaitan pengiraan quantum. Setiap video disertai modul interaktif
yang dipautkan dalam deskripsi di bawah. Jadi pastikan korang tengok. Kalau korang dah banyak dengar tentang komputer quantum korang
mungkin dah dengar bahawa komputer quantum boleh guna fenomena quantum seperti superposisi belitan dan gangguan untuk menyelesaikan
masalah dengan cara yang tak boleh dilakukan komputer klasikal. Tapi bagaimana sebenarnya ciri-ciri ini membantu? Pada tahun 1985 David Deutsch adalah
yang pertama menunjukkan bagaimana ini boleh berlaku. Dia mencipta apa yang kini dipanggil algoritma Deutsch yang boleh menyelesaikan
masalah lebih cekap daripada algoritma klasikal. Hari ini kita akan tengok algoritma Deutsch dan
sambungan kemudiannya yang dipanggil algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa dan mengkaji bagaimana aspek quantum yang unik pada Qubit
boleh digunakan untuk manfaat komputer quantum. Kemudian kita akan jalankan algoritma ini pada komputer quantum sebenar dengan Qiskit.
Ada algoritma quantum lain di luar sana yang juga menunjukkan kelebihan teori berbanding algoritma klasikal yang diketahui. Dan tidak semua daripada mereka berfungsi
dengan prinsip yang sama dengan yang akan kita lihat hari ini. Jadi apa yang kita pelajari hari ini tidak menerangkan secara umum bagaimana komputer quantum
berfungsi tapi ia membantu kita mula melihat bagaimana prinsip mekanik quantum boleh digabungkan untuk
menjadikan komputer quantum yang berkuasa. Sebelum menyelami algoritma Deutsch jom kita fikir dulu tentang bagaimana komputer quantum
berbeza daripada komputer klasikal dan bagaimana itu mungkin memberi kita kelebihan dalam menyelesaikan masalah tertentu
Satu perbezaan adalah bit quantum yang dipanggil Qubit boleh berada dalam keadaan superposisi. Bukannya terhad
kepada sama ada keadaan sifar atau keadaan satu seperti bit klasikal sebuah Qubit
boleh berada dalam keadaan superposisi kedua-dua sifar dan satu. Kita tulis keadaan ini seperti
ini di mana a dan b adalah nombor kompleks yang kuasanya tambah hingga satu dan lebih
banyak Qubit lebih besar jurang ini meluas. Dua bit masih hanya boleh berada dalam satu daripada
empat keadaan yang mungkin. 0 0 1 1 0 atau 1
1. Dua Qubit boleh berada dalam superposisi semua empat daripada keadaan yang dibenarkan secara klasikal yang
ditulis seperti ini. Secara umumnya sistem klasikal dengan n bit hanya boleh berada dalam satu daripada 2 kepada n yang mungkin
kombinasi sifar dan satu. Sistem quantum dengan n Qubit boleh berada dalam superposisi semua 2 kepada n daripada keadaan
ini. Penskalaan adalah eksponen. Jadi walaupun kita hanya ada 10 Qubit mereka
boleh berada dalam keadaan superposisi 2 kepada 10 iaitu 1024 kemungkinan kombinasi sifar dan
satu. Penskalaan eksponen ruang keadaan Qubit dipanggil
keselarian quantum dan sebahagiannya bertanggungjawab terhadap kelebihan komputer quantum berbanding komputer klasikal. Tapi komputer quantum
bukan sekadar pemproses selari yang besar. Hanya kerana Qubit dalam komputer quantum boleh berada dalam
superposisi daripada banyak keadaan secara eksponen tak bermakna kita boleh akses semua maklumat dalam setiap daripada keadaan
ini. Kerana pengukuran meruntuhkan sistem kepada satu keadaan atau yang lain jom kita
lihat bagaimana ini berlaku dalam masalah yang mudah. Katakan ada sebuah mesin yang
boleh korang masukkan satu bit. Kemudian ia akan menerapkan beberapa fungsi pada bit dan mengeluarkan bit tunggal lain. Mesin
itu berada di dalam kotak hitam yang tidak boleh kita akses. Semua yang kita ada akses adalah bit
yang kita masukkan x dan bit yang kotak keluarkan f
bagi x. Kita nak cari tahu apakah fungsi f yang digunakan mesin.
Ada empat fungsi yang mungkin yang mengambil satu bit kepada satu bit lain.
Jadi untuk mengetahui apakah fungsinya kita boleh masukkan sifar dan tengok sama ada ia mengeluarkan sifar atau satu. kemudian masukkan
satu dan buat perkara yang sama. Setiap daripada dua langkah ini dipanggil pertanyaan. Ini
adalah satu cara untuk membandingkan algoritma klasikal dan quantum melalui model pertanyaan yang dipanggil di mana kita bandingkan bilangan
pertanyaan yang perlu dibuat oleh setiap algoritma pada kotak hitam untuk menyelesaikan masalah. Jadi dalam kes ini
kaedah klasikal kita perlu membuat pertanyaan pada kotak dua kali untuk mengetahui fungsinya. Jom tengok sama ada kita boleh buat lebih baik kalau kita ada komputer quantum
yang membuat pertanyaan pada kotak hitam. Bukannya dulu memasukkan sifar kemudian satu
komputer quantum boleh memasukkan kotak dengan Qubit yang berada dalam superposisi sifar dan
satu. Jadi pada dasarnya kita memasukkan kedua-dua input dengan satu pertanyaan. Kemudian
adakah itu bermakna kita boleh mengetahui fungsinya dengan hanya satu pertanyaan?
Malangnya itu bukan kasusnya. Kita tengok kenapa idea ini gagal bila kita uji pada komputer quantum. Kita akan buat
circuit dengan dua Qubit. Qubit sifar yang diwakili di sini oleh garisan atas ini akan menjadi keadaan input X yang kita masukkan ke
kotak hitam yang ditunjukkan di sini oleh gate berwarna merah marun berlabel UF. Gate UF
direka untuk mengambil Qubit sifar sebagai keadaan input X kemudian menerapkan transformasi pada Qubit satu yang
mengambil keadaan sifar kepada keadaan f bagi x. Jadi selagi Qubit 1 bermula dalam keadaan
sifar maka output adalah x pada Qubit 0 dan f bagi x pada Qubit 1. Jadi untuk mencari f bagi x untuk
kedua-dua x=0 dan x=1 secara serentak kita boleh cuba meletakkan Qubit 0 dalam superposisi 0 dan 1 sebelum
kita masukkan ke kotak hitam. Itu dilakukan dengan gate Hadamard merah ini yang mengubah keadaan sifar kepada 1/2
0+1. Jadi selepas gate kotak hitam kita sepatutnya kini mempunyai superposisi kedua-dua
f bagi 0 dan f bagi 1 pada Qubit 1. Bila kita ukur dua Qubit kita berharap untuk
menjawab soalan apakah fungsi di dalam kotak hitam. Jom guna sampler primitive Qiskit untuk jalankan
circuit dan pulangkan hasilnya. Kita boleh pilih bilangan kali circuit dijalankan yang dipanggil sampel dengan menukar parameter
yang dipanggil shots ini.
WEBVTT
Ini setara dengan bilangan pertanyaan yang kita buat pada kotak hitam. Jom tengok sama ada satu pertanyaan sahaja akan
berjaya. Inilah hasilnya. Kita ukur Qubit 0 menjadi sifar. Jadi itulah nilai
input x dan Qubit 1 menjadi 1 yang merupakan nilai output f bagi x. Jadi kini kita
tahu f bagi 0 sama dengan 1. Tapi macam mana dengan f bagi 1? Di sinilah masalahnya. Setelah
kita ukur keadaan superposisi runtuh dan kita hanya berjaya mengukur satu bahagian fungsi dengan satu
pertanyaan. Ini tak memberitahu kita semua yang kita perlu tahu untuk menentukan fungsi yang mana. Kita perlukan
pertanyaan kedua pada kotak untuk itu. Jadi walaupun prinsip keselarian quantum membolehkan kita secara serentak
meminta kotak hitam menilai f bagi 0 dan f bagi 1 kita tak ada akses kepada kedua-dua
jawapan itu. Keselarian quantum sahaja tidak cukup. Algoritma Deutsch
menunjukkan bagaimana kita boleh guna keselarian quantum dengan cara yang sedikit berbeza untuk mengetahui tentang fungsi di dalam kotak hitam. Kita tak akan
dapat mengetahui dengan tepat apakah fungsinya tapi kita akan dapat mengetahui sesuatu yang baru tentangnya dengan satu
pertanyaan yang tak boleh kita lakukan dengan komputer klasikal. Jom mulakan dengan melihat carta empat fungsi yang mungkin
yang mengambil satu bit kepada satu bit lain. Di sini korang boleh lihat bahawa dua daripada fungsi f_sub_1 dan f_sub_4 sentiasa
mengembalikan nilai tunggal tanpa mengira keadaan input. Kita panggil dua fungsi ini
malar. f_sub_2 dan f_sub_3 akan mengembalikan sama ada sifar atau satu bergantung pada
keadaan x. Kita panggil dua fungsi ini seimbang. Algoritma Deutsch
menentukan sama ada fungsi adalah malar atau seimbang dengan membuat beberapa pelarasan bijak pada circuit yang kita guna
sebelumnya. Inilah circuit tersebut. Ia bermula dengan menyediakan Qubit 0 dalam keadaan 1/
2 0+1 dengan Hadamard seperti sebelumnya dan Qubit 1 dalam keadaan 1/2 0-1
dengan gate NOT diikuti oleh Hadamard.
Jadi keadaan penuh pada titik ini di sini adalah di mana ini adalah keadaan Qubit 0 dan
ini adalah keadaan Qubit 1. Menyediakan Qubit satu dengan cara ini berbanding hanya
membiarkannya dalam keadaan sifar membolehkan algoritma menggunakan keselarian quantum digabungkan dengan gangguan untuk mengetahui
tentang fungsi kotak hitam. Jom tengok bila Qubit dimasukkan ke dalam UF gate kotak hitam beberapa perkara boleh
berlaku. Kalau fungsinya malar maka kotak hitam akan menjalankan beberapa operasi pada Qubit satu sahaja tanpa mengira
keadaan sifar. Dalam kes ini memandangkan UF tidak menyentuh Qubit sifar atau
ambil kisah tentang keadaannya maka Hadamard kedua di sini hanya membatalkan apa yang
Hadamard pertama lakukan. Dan kita akan ukur Qubit berada dalam keadaan sifar. Jom tengok fungsi seimbang f_sub_2 sebagai contoh untuk melihat
apa yang dilakukan uf pada keadaan dalam kes ini. Bila x adalah sifar f bagi x adalah sifar dan bila x
adalah 1 f bagi x adalah 1. Ingat apa yang saya beritahu korang tentang gate uf. Ia mengambil Qubit 0
sebagai keadaan input x dan mengeluarkan f bagi x pada Qubit 1. Dengan andaian Qubit 1
bermula dalam keadaan sifar. Jadi untuk fungsi ini apa yang dilakukan UF pada Qubit 1 bergantung
pada Qubit 0. Kalau 0 adalah sifar maka Qubit 1 akan dibiarkan dalam keadaan sifar untuk mendapatkan f
bagi x=0. Kalau Qubit 0 adalah 1 kotak hitam akan menerapkan gate NOT pada Qubit 1 dan meletakkannya
dalam keadaan satu. Jadi kita mendapat f bagi 1 sama dengan 1. Ini adalah tepat apa yang dilakukan oleh gate controlled-NOT atau gate C-NOT. Gate
C-NOT mengambil dua Qubit sebuah Qubit kawalan dan Qubit sasaran dan membalikkan
keadaan Qubit sasaran jika Qubit kawalan berada dalam keadaan satu. Tapi ia tidak buat apa-apa pada sasaran kalau Qubit kawalan
berada dalam keadaan sifar. Jadi UF untuk F2 hanyalah C-NOT pada Q0 dan Q1. Gate C-NOT
tidak akan melakukan apa-apa pada sebutan pertama kerana Qubit kawalan berada dalam keadaan sifar. Tapi pada sebutan kedua
sifar ini bertukar kepada satu dan satu ini bertukar kepada sifar. Dan kalau kita faktorkan tanda tolak kita akan nampak bahawa keadaan Qubit 1
tidak berubah. Tapi sebutan ini telah dapat tanda tolak. Jadi keadaan Qubit 0
sebenarnya yang telah berubah. Ia berubah dari 0+1 menjadi 0 tolak
satu. Bila kita terapkan Hadamard akhir pada Qubit 0 ini mengubahnya kepada keadaan 1. Jadi kalau fungsi dalam kotak hitam
adalah f_sub_2 kita akan ukur satu bukannya sifar. Rupanya gate UF untuk fungsi seimbang lain f3 adalah
gate C-NOT yang sama diikuti oleh NOT pada Qubit 1. Gate NOT akhir itu tidak mempengaruhi Qubit sifar. Jadi bila fungsi
adalah seimbang kita akan ukur Qubit 0 berada dalam keadaan satu di akhir circuit. Sekarang kalau korang tak ikut semua
ini tak apa. Saya sarankan korang teliti sendiri untuk tengok bagaimana ia berfungsi. Perkara utama di sini adalah apa yang
berlaku bila kita terapkan C-NOT untuk dua fungsi seimbang. Qubit 0 hanya digunakan sebagai Qubit kawalan untuk mengubah
keadaan Qubit 1. Secara intuitif korang mungkin fikir bahawa Qubit 0 akan kekal tidak berubah. Namun entah macam mana
operasi kita pada Qubit satu sebenarnya mengubah keadaan Qubit sifar dengan mengubah fasa relatif antara dua bahagian
superposisinya. Fenomena ini dikenali sebagai mekanisme tendangan balik fasa dan ia
sangat berlawanan intuisi seperti banyak fenomena quantum. Dengan cara tertentu korang boleh fikir tentang mekanisme tendangan balik fasa
seperti mendayung bot. Tindakan menolak air ke belakang sebenarnya mendorong korang ke hadapan. Sama seperti operasi pada
Qubit 1 sebenarnya mengubah Qubit sifar. Sekarang kita boleh jalankan algoritma Deutsch pada
Qiskit. Di sini kita boleh pilih fungsi mana yang nak dimasukkan ke dalam kotak hitam yang kita pilih F3. Inilah
gambar rajah circuit algoritma dan kita boleh jalankan seperti sebelumnya dengan sampler primitive. Kita akan tetapkan bilangan
sampel kepada satu sahaja dan tengok apa yang kita ukur. Dalam kes ini kita ukur satu.
Jadi kita tahu bahawa fungsinya adalah seimbang yang memang adalah apa yang kita jangkakan kerana kotak hitam mengandungi fungsi f3. Jadi dengan hanya satu
pertanyaan kita berjaya membezakan antara dua kelas fungsi ini.
Ini memerlukan dua pertanyaan oleh algoritma klasikal untuk ditentukan. Ini menunjukkan kelebihan yang sederhana daripada pengiraan quantum
berbanding pengiraan klasikal sahaja tapi ia tak terlalu mengagumkan. Hanya satu berbanding dua. Tapi algoritma Deutsch
WEBVTT
masih sangat penting dalam sejarah pengiraan quantum kerana ia memberikan percikan yang mendorong orang lain
untuk memikirkan algoritma quantum yang lebih besar dan lebih canggih.
Ini termasuk sambungan berbilang Qubit bagi algoritma Deutsch yang menunjukkan kelebihan quantum yang jauh lebih mengagumkan.
Ini dipanggil algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa. Ia menyelesaikan masalah yang serupa tapi dalam kes ini fungsi kotak hitam
yang ingin kita ketahui mengambil n bit sebagai input dan mengeluarkan satu bit. Seperti
sebelumnya kita dijanjikan bahawa fungsinya sama ada malar bermaksud bit output sentiasa satu atau sentiasa sifar
tanpa mengira rentetan bit input atau seimbang bermaksud output adalah sifar untuk
separuh daripada rentetan bit input dan satu untuk separuh yang lain. Tentu saja ada
fungsi lain yang mengambil n bit kepada satu bit yang bukan malar atau seimbang. Tapi dalam masalah ini kita
dijanjikan bahawa tiada daripada fungsi-fungsi itu berada di dalam kotak hitam. Yang ada dalam kotak dijamin sama ada malar
atau seimbang. Circuit Deutsch-Jozsa kelihatan serupa dengan algoritma Deutsch tapi dengan lebih banyak Qubit. Di sini kita ada
pelaksanaan algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa untuk mengetahui tentang fungsi tiga bit. Kali ini kita ada tiga Qubit
untuk keadaan input bukannya hanya satu. Dan kemudian kita ada Qubit terakhir ini untuk keadaan output. Seperti sebelumnya sekali lagi
kita sediakan semua Qubit input untuk berada dalam keadaan 0+satu dan Qubit output
untuk berada dalam keadaan 0 tolak satu. Kemudian walaupun matematik sedikit lebih rumit untuk diikuti prinsipnya
tetap sama. Kalau fungsinya malar ia tidak akan bergantung pada tiga Qubit atas langsung. Jadi keadaan mereka
akan berubah semula kepada sifar selepas Hadamard kedua dan pengukuran kita akan menghasilkan rentetan tiga bit semua
sifar. Tapi kalau fungsinya seimbang maka bila kita ukur Qubit selepas Hadamard mekanisme tendangan balik fasa
akan menyebabkan satu atau lebih daripada bit itu menjadi satu. Mungkin tak mudah untuk dilihat kali ini tapi kalau korang kerjakan
setiap langkah sendiri korang akan segera nampak ini mesti begitu. Satu cara untuk menyemak ini adalah cuba mengira
kebarangkalian mengukur semua sifar dengan fungsi seimbang. Korang patut mendapat kebarangkalian sifar. Jom jalankan
algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa pada komputer quantum dengan Qiskit. Langkah yang paling sukar mungkin adalah mencipta fungsi Deutsch-Jozsa
itu. Itu akan menjadi kotak hitam kita yang kita buat pertanyaan di sini. Kod ini menghasilkan fungsi Deutsch-Jozsa rawak yang
dijamin sama ada seimbang atau malar. Kemudian kita buat circuit Deutsch-Jozsa kita memasukkan fungsi kotak hitam kita
di sini. Sekali lagi kita jalankan circuit dengan sampler dan selepas kita ukur kita tengok
bit yang diukur untuk menentukan sama ada fungsinya seimbang atau malar.
Kalau semua sifar ia adalah malar. Tapi kalau ada sekurang-kurangnya satu bit satu dalam rentetan maka ia adalah seimbang. Dalam
kes ini kita mendapat rentetan bit 1 satu satu.
Jadi kita tahu bahawa fungsinya adalah seimbang. Saya harap saya dah bagi korang peluang pertama untuk melihat bagaimana algoritma quantum
boleh mengambil kesempatan daripada fenomena quantum yang menarik dan sering halus untuk mendapat kelebihan berbanding algoritma klasikal
Korang mungkin juga dah perasan betapa rumitnya untuk mereka bentuk algoritma quantum. Walaupun yang pertama sekali pun
memerlukan banyak kreativiti untuk mencapai hanya kemenangan yang sederhana berbanding kaedah klasikal. Dan sejak algoritma pertama itu
ahli fizik dan saintis komputer terus muncul dengan cara yang sangat kreatif untuk menggunakan mekanik quantum
untuk kelebihan mereka termasuk sambungan dan aplikasi lanjut algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa. Kalau korang nak
belajar tentang beberapa daripada ini serta cuba sendiri algoritma Deutsch dan Deutsch-Jozsa pergi ke
modul yang dipautkan dalam deskripsi untuk mulakan. Terima kasih kerana menonton dan jumpa korang kali berikutnya.